2010neuf aura été l'année louis roberge
et mais un agronome n'aura autant fait
parler de lui
lanceur d' alerte il a propulsé à
l'avant-scène le dossier des pesticides
voici un bref rappel des événements
suivi de l'entrevue qu'il nous a accordé
fonctionnaires pendant plus de trente
ans au ministère québécois de
l'agriculture
louis robert lève le voile sur des
pratiques dans le milieu de la recherche
agronomique
il y à une pression de l'industrie sont
de la recherche qui est public
ils dénoncent l'ingérence de l'industrie
qui empêche la publication d'études
financées par le gouvernement sur les
néonicotinoïdes des semences enrobées de
ces pesticides tueurs d'abeilles sont
utilisés dans près de 100% des champs de
maïs au québec
pourtant la recherche démontre que ces
produits n'apporte pas de hausse de
rendement significative
louis robert mettra son emploi en jeu
pour que ces données soient connus du
grand public en janvier 2019
il est congédié l'addition qui était
paypal ou c'est sûr que j'ai
personnellement autorisé une décision
qui provoque un tollé en juin la
protectrice du citoyen blâme sévèrement
le ministère de l'agriculture jeu au nom
de l'état québécois m'excuser auprès de
louis robert l'agronome retrouve son
emploi au début du mois d'août je serais
heureux dénouement du gerddes demander
des mandats les dossiers en septembre il
témoigne à la commission parlementaire
sur les pesticides à québec commission
annoncée dans la foulée de son
congédiement à ce que les lieux sont
trop puissants je ne crois pas les
lobbys ne sont pas ce soir que ça c'est
que nous n'avons affirmé aucune
opposition
nous avons été fait
[Musique]
monsieur robert 2019 ça a été une année
chargée
je pense qu'on peut le dire qu'est ce
qu'on doit retenir de cette année là je
passe une année de changements cette
année de prise de conscience et je pense
qu'il est plus que temps qu'il ya une
prise de conscience parce que on a
souvent travaillé en vase clos en
écriture et d'un milieu économique aussi
alors que là c'est tout à coup ça se
trouve
ouvert au public à discussion aux
échanges au forum à la remise en
question des pratiques et c'est juste
possible parce qu'on en a vraiment
besoin non on sait maintenant que la
recherche ne justifiait pas
l'utilisation systématique de certains
pesticides
puis on lise vous êtes quand même donc
et sur le grand public s'est pris
conscience de soi puis ça ça peut faire
avancer les choses
vous dites c'est positif cette prise de
conscience là la commission
parlementaire sur les pesticides
en même temps il ya beaucoup
d'agriculteurs qui se sont sentis montré
du doigt une grande quand même dans le
milieu agricole qu'est ce que vous
répondez aux producteurs on a un
objectif de réduction du temps de
pesticides depuis longtemps et ça ne
fonctionne pas à répétition depuis 25
ans on n'a toujours pas de résultat
positif sur la réduction des pesticides
au contraire sa demande
[Musique]
donc on a un problème pourquoi ça ne
fonctionne pas dans le diagnostic moi ce
que j'ai trouvé les portes du temps
n'atteint pas les premiers responsables
de la situation au pas du tout je pense
être dans l'encadrement est aujourd'hui
derrière dans mon mémoire à la
commission
c'est ce que j'ai dit je pense et
l'encadrement l'encadrement dont il
parle ce sont les services conseils que
les agriculteurs vont chercher auprès
d'un agronome pour les guider dans la
gestion des champs louis robert dénonce
l'omniprésence du secteur privé sur le
terrain et la situation de conflit
d'intérêts dans laquelle se retrouvent
les agronomes qui pose un diagnostic
ils vendent ensuite des produits pour
remédier au problème provenait du coup
selon lui il existe un éventail de
solutions autres que des pesticides qui
ne sont pas mises de l'avant son volant
c'est en termes de réduction du temps je
postule c'est ce qui va falloir faire ce
geste là de se parer la vente de
produits dans la condamnation et il
faudra mettre de l'avant des méthodes
alternatives aux pesticides ce qu'on
appelle la lutte intégrée la lutte en
premier lieu d'augmenter la biodiversité
le phare de ce dépistage pour
véritablement voir constater oui j'ai un
problème
voici de le corriger par des méthodes
douces actuellement usage des pesticides
souvent ces mêmes en prévention avant
même qu'on ait vu l'apparition du
symptôme de la mauvaise herbe la maladie
ou d'un siècle
donc on est rendus loin alors à l'autre
extrême il faut reprendre les principes
de l'été des grès est constatée par du
dépistage ce que j'ai un problème vous
pas psychose et par quoi faire un
raisonnement avec un encadrement grand
ami de professionnels non liés aux à la
fourniture des trains
[Musique]
la compétence en l'hôtellerie à sauve
pas de côté les compagnies sont en mal
c'est leur raison d'être que de vente du
produit
la compétence à l'oedt intégré et du
côté du matin et des deux conseils à
l'agroenvironnement et alors que les
résidus de pesticides sont omniprésents
dans les rivières où l'on puise notre
eau potable
le temps presse pour agir il faut un
changement de pratiques culturales le
système ne seront pas le pot de
changement de molécules par un autre et
on parle d'intégration à vitesse grand
envie de pratiquer que certaines pour du
temps d'avant garde pratique déjà ils
font la demande a constamment
enfin comme les avant gardistes cp1
c'est pas un sacrifice qui forme qui
baissent pas le rendement ça affecte pas
du tout le ramenant au comptant souvent
des gens qui pour les pratiques les plus
respectueux de l'environnement
les pop stars sont ceux qui produisent
les plus beaux romans de rythme et on
libère rentabilité aussi donc les
pratiques qu'on met de l'allant
quand on parle de lutte intégrée quand
on parle de rotation culture de culture
de couverture etc
c'est des pratiques je me dirai ce sont
toutes des pratiques qui remplissent les
troubles auditifs simultanément sa
meilleure année meilleure rentabilité
est plus faibles impacts
environnementaux
l'argument le plus convaincant c'est que
ça se passe sur des fermes actuellement
donc il faut étendre ces pratiques l'eau
fera connaître la bonne nouvelle aux
autres ils savent ni sans doute sûrement
mais il ya des obstacles
pourquoi le message passe pas en grande
partie parce qu'il ya des influences et
du l'apport de l'industrie des des
compagnies de semences pesticides est
aussi que sur le terrain beaucoup de
conseillers sont employées par ces
compétitions
donc si on voulait réduire les
pesticides entre potes partie des
bastides parmi les plus toxiques
ça serait d'enlever ces traitements de
semences et s'est il pas juste les
néonicotinoïdes mais toutes les
effectifs sur les annonces
donc ça c'est un geste qui est très
facile à faire et on a tous les outils
pour la voir
ça réduirait beaucoup d indice de risque
pour la santé pour l'environnement mais
le message peine à passer
on est à la fin 2019 bon il s'est passé
plein de chose qu'est ce qui pour
l'avenir vous inquiète le plus la santé
des sols c'est certainement l'enjeu qui
me préoccupe le plus pour l'avenir parce
que ce qu'on constate en général ça
s'améliore pour paradoxalement sur
certaines entreprises ça s'améliore et u
dégage des revenus de plus en plus
récents mais dans l'ensemble des fermes
au québec
j'ai fait des diagnostics de santé des
sols dans toutes les régions nab sur
beaucoup de fermes et en général on sent
aussi longtemps qu'on soit pas prêt à
accepter qu'il faut changer nos
pratiques plus respectueuses puis à mes
demeures structure une infiltration du
sol ben sahar confiance dégradé pour
améliorer la structure d'un sol l'une
des clef c'est de travailler avec des
racines vivante donc ne jamais laisser
la terre à nu optez pour des cultures
intercalaires des cultures de couverture
et réduire au maximum le travail du sol
il faut convaincre les producteurs que
c'est gagnant pour tout le monde c'est
d'abord gagner pour eux on sous estime
les bénéfices monétaires qu'on peut
tirer d'une seule qui est en santé un
sol bien structuré il produit des
rendements qui sont entre 40 50 % plus
élevé que le même type de sol mêlée
pendant 10
[Musique]
sauf que pour remettre un seul en santé
il faut de la patience et de la
persévérance est un écosystème très
complète le sol et ça ne l'est j'ai pas
la journée même évidemment les mêmes
dans une saison ça peut prendre trois à
cinq ans qu'on me dit avant que l'
équilibre améliorée se retrouvent après
avoir instauré les pratiques à adopter
de bonnes pratiques
c'est peut-être ce qui fait que ça
serait pas plus et que les effets sont
pas instantané quand on a un problème de
santé des sols quand on nous promet de
santé de culture a fait tous les humains
sont pareils cas cela on veut remettre
et on veut que ça soit efficace
rapidement qu'on veut su corriger le
problème vite alors que dans le sol
comme c'est un écosystème très complexe
il ya déséquilibre qui s'établit à
seulement qu'au bout d'un certain temps
et si adopter de nouvelles pratiques
peut sembler exigeant louis robert
souligne qu'au moins c'est abordable
certains posteurs rechigne à se payer
les services d'un agronome ou encore
investir dans les cultures de couverture
c'est pas vrai que ça coûte les ninjas
tête la ram est une terre en santé c'est
pas vrai non plus ça coûte les yeux de
la tête
enfin ça coûte moins cher que de la
laisser contenait le dégrader ça c'est
sûr et les pratiques on préconise c'est
pas des choses courchesne
le temps presse il va falloir qu'on s'y
attaque est réellement
les milieux environnants nous dit que on
est allé trop loin de ce côté là et là
quelques nous allemands nous le dit
aussi
et la santé humaine ou si nous le dit
donc il faut aussi rapidement possible
mettre en place ces pratiques là surtout
les réponses à partir des entreprises
sont à l'avant garde dans ce secteur là
les faire adopter par le plus grand
nombre et l'ombre un impact massif sur
la qualité d'environnement la qualité
des animaux la santé humaine aussi
[Musique]
e